So, we will just create a new material for this which I will right click, I got some
material I'm going to call this M underscore, I'm just going to call this master, let's
say master for now and I'm going to hit enter and then enter again and so I want to actually
hold down T this time so I'll go to T and press left click, I'm going to create four
of these so T left click, T left click, T left click and T left click, I mean alternative
you can just copy and paste so I could hit control C, control V if I wanted to copy and
paste but because it's T and left click it's quite a straightforward command to use, I'm
going to plug one into my base color, I'm going to plug one into my metallic, going
to get a roughness and I will use a normal map in this instance so we're going to normal.
Now you can see that we're error in red so let's just plug in some textures here so let's
go back to our content browser and actually the thing that I keep just not getting used
to in Unreal Engine 5, let's make use of it now, in our material we can hit control
and space bar and we can open the drawer here which is a really really handy tool for those
of you who used previous versions for Unreal Engine that didn't have this, you can see
what kind of lifesaver it is but let's go ahead and add this white square material first
so we want to go to engine content and so instead of the main content you want to go
to engine content now and for whatever reason you can't see engine content you can come
over to settings on the right hand side here and just make sure you show engine content
so we're looking out for the engine content here and then I believe it's called white
square texture so we can use either one of these I think they're both the same, yeah
well let's go for the first one I think you'll be fine with either but let's just go with
the first one for now so we can plug that in there we can select this texture sample
and under texture we can just plug that in because we've got it selected in our previous
window we'll also apply that to the roughness as well now we want to find a black texture
so we'll type in black and I think it's that first one yeah let's go for the black one
by one let's put that in there and let's assign that so we're just because we've got it assigned
in a quick draw by pressing ctrl and spacebar we are then oh there's two more up here let's
go with the first one I think that's going to be the safer one to pick so let's just
hit black there that's good and then ctrl and spacebar and now let's type in T underscore
normal make sure we spell that correctly and then we want this T underscore normal and
then we'll go back here select the last texture sample plug that in and then we'll hit save so
what we've got here is we've got a placeholder materials placeholder texture sample sorry for
our material and then what we'll do in a similar way that we did the the previous material instance
with the colors we can just right-click and convert this to a parameter so we'll call this
albedo texture we'll right-click the next one convert to a parameter and call this metallic
texture and you can imagine what the next one is going to be so right-click convert to parameter
we'll call this roughness texture and then last one we'll call this one normal texture so
convert to parameter normal texture and so if we save and then go to our content browser which
again I'm just going to open my draw here which goes ctrl and spacebar I'm going to zero out any
such bar information I'm going to go back to my materials folder on my master material I'm going
to right-click create a material instance I'm just going to call this mi master maybe I'll call this
mi underscore master this is where you probably want a prefix of like m underscore master underscore
would underscore o1 for example so then you can have this big parent material and then you can
define based on the material type but I'm just going to call this o1 for now just so we get an
idea I'm going to hit enter to open it and you'll see that we now have some global texture parameters
so we can actually enable all these and we can now plug in whatever textures we want into these
different values and that will then create a different material based on that so really nice
quick way to have this master material and to create some instances from that